let me tell you about the situation I
had in 1970. we were going out on an
audition for Woody Allen's bananas and
they were looking for two muggers so we
went to the location which was in a
Subway and Woody Allen turned to him
whispered something and then walked away
and the assistant director faced us and
said he doesn't think you're
intimidating enough
okay that's a first goal my friend I'm
out of here he says don't quit he says
well we have to change his mind let's go
into a pharmacy get some Vaseline put it
on her hair put it on her face this and
that we did we walked back into this
Subway I saw Woody Allen tap him in the
shoulders spun around and he startled
and I go do I intimidate you now
do I you know overdoing it because okay
it's good you're good you're good like
that and we got the parts sometimes
have to bend it could Port they're
normally presented with a normal
audition isn't that you have to change
it up sometimes you have to kick down
the door sometimes you climb through a
window sometimes you just change your
presentation